Pressure ulcers, also called
bedsores, are regions of skin that are
injured when you sit or lie
in one position for a long time. These
wounds most often occur in
areas where the bones are close to the
skin, including heels, ankles,
hips, coccyx, or elbows.
constant pressure in one of these
areas compresses the blood vessels that
supply vital oxygen and nutrients
to the skin
without a sufficient amount of
blood flow the skin cells
eventually die and a
pressure ulcer forms pressure ulcers
are categorized by grade  of
severity a
stage 1 pressure ulcer is red, swollen and does
not turn pale when pressure is applied
a
stage 2 pressure ulcer appears as a blister or
open sore the
area around the sore may be red and
sore  a stage 3 pressure ulcer
involves a full-thickness skin loss
that resembles a crater  er and
extends to the layer of
fat under the skin stage 4
is the most severe a stage 4 ulcer
is a full-thickness wound that
extends to the underlying muscle and bone
to prevent infection of an ulcer
your doctor will clean the wound using water
and a mild soap or serum
if your wound is severe your doctor will
provide or surgically
remove dead tissue from the pressure ulcer
to protect and moisturize the wound your
doctor may cover it with a
specialized bandage